à 7 ans où les annales parmi les plus
jeunes ukrainiennes à soutenir l'effort
de guerre
ici on récupère les tissus pour les
mèches des cocktails molotov
un peu plus loin on gratte du
polystyrène utilisé pour les mélanges
chimiques des cocktails molotov
c'est ici qu'ils sont fabriqués par ces
femmes qui travaillent sans répit celle
ci pense particulièrement à son mari en
étant ici je l'aide
même si j'aimerais lui être avec lui sur
la ligne de front pour jeter s'était mis
hors de notre pays
et voici comment les civils ukrainien
jette ses bombes artisanales sur les
blindés russes
dans cet atelier de couture les
stylistes ne fabrique plus détenus ou
des accessoires de mode mais bien des
treillis et des gilets pare balles
la plaque de métal est envoyé par un
autre groupe de résistance et elle est
testée à balles réelles
troisième
des protections d'autant plus utile que
les barricades s'élève à dnipro
des femmes parmi les ouvriers mais aussi
parmi les soldats comme anna docteur est
engagé
je suis ici je n'ai pas peur et mon fils
de 21 ans s'est engagé aussi
depuis 2018 les femmes sont considérées
comme les égales des hommes dans l'armée
ukrainienne elle représente aujourd'hui
15% des effectifs militaires